لقد جئنا إلى هذا الشاطئ حيث نعلم أن عمليات
عبور قوارب المهاجرين قد حدثت
لفهم الظروف
المحيطة بالمأساة التي أودت بحياة 27 شخصًا يوم
الأربعاء بشكل أفضل وعندما تأتي إلى هنا ،
هناك بعض الأشياء الرئيسية حول هذه القصة
التي تفهمها أولاً وقبل كل
شيء  200 كيلومتر من
الخط الساحلي
المهم في شمال فرنسا يبدو مثل هذا
الذي يوفر أرضًا مواتية للغاية
لكل من المهربين والمهاجرين ،
ترون كل هذه الكثبان الرملية الصغيرة التي لا تعد ولا تحصى من
الزوايا والشقوق ليختبئوا بها ،
وتحدثنا إلى الشرطة المحلية قالوا لنا أن 13
مهاجرا كانوا  تم العثور عليها في الكثبان الرملية مثل هذه ،
هناك بالأمس ،
لذا فإن التضاريس الملائمة ، ثانيًا ، انظر إلى
هذا ، هذا أحد القوارب التي
قدمها المهربون
للمهاجرين يبلغ طوله حوالي 10 أمتار وهو
زورق قابل للنفخ مثل الزورق الذي
انقلب يوم الأربعاء
هذا هو
مثالي للمهربين ، من السهل شراءه
بسهولة إلى حد ما ،
وهذا هو الجزء السفلي من القارب ،
هذه الألواح الخشبية هنا  كما
تم قطعه ، تم قطعه من قبل الشرطة الفرنسية بحيث
لا يمكن استخدامه بعد الآن ، من
الواضح أنه تم اعتراض هذا النموذج ، لكن يمكنك أن ترى
كيف يغذي هذا نموذج أعمالهم الذي
أخبرنا به وزير الداخلية الفرنسي في
كثير من الأحيان يتم شراء قوارب مثل هذه في
ألمانيا وتقول الشرطة
يمكننا غالبًا دفن إحداثيات نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS)
ثم توصيلها
ويمكن للمهاجرين اكتشافهم وتضخيمهم
بسهولة إلى حد ما ، وهذا سوف يحمل
عشرات المهاجرين خاصةً
أن المهربين معروفون بأنهم يفرطون في تحميل
هذه القوارب بحيث يجلسون على مستوى منخفض جدًا
على الماء الذي يمكن أن يكون  خطير
للغاية وعندما يحين
الوقت ، يمكن للمهاجرين أن يأخذوهم إلى
البحر ،
هذا هو الدرس الثالث والأخير
للوقوف هنا على هذا الكثبان الرملية ،
يمكننا أن نرى منحدرات دوفر
هناك ، نحن على بعد 27 ميلًا بحريًا من
إنجلترا وهي الدورادو.  هذا
هو المكان الذي يريد هؤلاء المهاجرون
الوصول إليه
ولهذا السبب يواصلون القدوم إلى هنا
سيريل فانير بالقرب من كاليه فرنسا